so shane why show
this story if it is depressing why spend
five years plus of your life
delving into it i understand you know
that that judgment of some people that
are designated as you know sort of the
pundits able to talk about it and not be
judged whereas those that are artists
are more you know trashed or or brought
down in some way branded as evil because
they want to
show light about something but what was
it about this story that you felt you
needed to explore and spend so much time
and energy and money and
resources on um
i guess to just jump into it basically
when i saw the picture of alyssa the
most famous one uh it was her like you
know just kind of making this claw you
know like she had all this
you know weird bad makeup on but she was
making like this you know claw figure at
the camera
um and on her arm she had a
like 50
really bad self like really just deep
scarred self-inflicted wounds on her arm
and i don't know if you can see but i
have exactly just that um
so i basically
felt like i was looking into a mirror
suddenly i was just like holy um i
mean mine aren't as visible anymore
because they're a lot older than hers
were probably you know
new um but i just was like that's i mean
they're i they were so identical it was
just like you know i mean it was just
like that's exactly what my arm looks
like and that's kind of trippy and being
a self-abuser
i already know that that
i can't understand or even picture a
fathom somebody's self-abuse is killing
somebody else it didn't make sense to me
if anything she would have killed
herself which she already tried to do
and so
i kind of felt
i guess i felt like i was looking into a
mirror in a way
and
i do know at one point right before i
started self-abusing when i was 13
i had thought of killing kids at my
school because i was bullied bullied so
bad
and um i literally had when i was in
eighth grade i literally had not a
single friend like not even the dorks
would be my friend
and um you know and uh because it was uh
it was predominantly a hispanic school
so i got picked on for being white um
you know i wasn't allowed to use the
bathroom i would get like people put gum
in my hair and they'd have to cut my
hair out you know to get the gum out and
you know just smack me over the head
with weapons you know just for like no
reason whatsoever other than walking you
know or trying to use the bathroom
and um
anyways it was so bad i was terrified to
go to school and so i actually mapped
out how i was gonna kill everybody at my
school but then i was like i don't have
guns so i was like okay so i honor
myself with kissing knives um because
that's the only weapon i could get
and um
but then what actually there's so many
things it's kind of hard to pinpoint one
i ended up seeing
blood all over the walls one day at
school like this like it went on for
like maybe 15 20 feet just blood on the
walls and it was one of the guys who i
wanted to up and uh he
was a big guy
and uh somebody still i don't know who
beat his ass but somebody beat him up
really bad this big guy who i couldn't
stand who would pick on me and uh it was
a bunch of people picked on me but he
was one of them and uh
it actually
not only frightened me seeing his blood
it's made me sad and i think that's when
i realized i could never hurt somebody
else
um and i could never especially with a
knife so that kind of raises i guess
maybe the gun control issue if i had a
gun maybe it would be a lot easier just
point and shoot but there's no way i
could have walked up to somebody and
stabbed them i mean i feel bad if i have
to kill a fly rather just go away you
know
and so um
that's when i decided i couldn't ever
hurt anybody and then i started
self-abusing and i thought that would
maybe make people afraid of me
um because i started by like grinding my
hands into the walls so i had no skin on
my knuckles so i thought maybe they
would think i beat somebody up or that's
kind of how it started you know the 13
year old my 13 year old mentality and
then it started leading into other stuff
and i didn't end up actually cutting
till i was 26 so it was like 13 years
later when it turned into i guess direct
you know
how would you say that you know i mean
like it was always other forms of
self-abuse it wasn't the cutting thing
um
and i totally forgot the question
because i told you i didn't go all
around in circles but it was uh that's
what made me want to um
so you saw his picture and you saw her
arm and there was something in her i saw
myself in her that's what it was um
and uh i guess there was a need to
understand that or or
could i
kill somebody like since i'm looking in
america i've killed somebody or why did
she do it there's just all these things
going through my head it was a need to
understand it
um
it was
outraged by just a media in general but
mainly her i just i was so sickened by
that lady it just and i know she does it
for show and
who knows maybe she's even a nice person
but but still she's selling out if she
is i mean that's just awful what she
does i think and um so that combined
with you know making me think about call
mine why i start i think a lot of things
are going on it's reminding me of the
coal mine thing and that's what actually
made me stop watching television and yet
you know i'm a filmmaker but i stopped
watching you know television which is
like a huge i think part of the industry
um
and so i just had so many things
floating through my head you know i
guess i was angry at the media
that was another thing too is
there's so many things a few months
earlier i tried to make a movie about
human trafficking and uh that was an
issue i've been
um it was in 2009 i i attempted to make
a
start started to get together an idea
for human trafficking and i've been
wanting to do it since 2005 when i first
had heard about
like sex trafficking
and um
so it would have been about you know sex
trafficking in particular and uh i'd
been spending months trying to figure
out
the story i could make and then this
girl ended up in the news jc degarde who
most people have
probably heard about if they've
you know
ever wanted to make a movie about human
trafficking
might have heard about this girl she
lived for 18 years as a slave to this
guy and had kids and then she ended up
being found um you know they thought she
was dead for almost two decades and they
found her and she was like
in 2009 she was like the most famous
i guess person in the world as far as
non-celebrity i would say i mean she was
just everywhere
and so when i heard the story i was like
oh i want to make a movie like that and
i announced it
thinking you know nobody's gonna you
know i announced it to like a couple
indie horror sites thinking nobody's
going to read this i just can use this
to maybe get a few actors i want you
know and i said i got the idea from the
jc the guard thing and because i made a
movie called amateur porn star killer
the next thing i noticed is posting uh
pornographer making jc degarde porno and
i'm like what the
like seriously
and um and then for about 48 hours i
became the most hated man in the world i
mean my
friends were like hey you're on the news
in ireland you're on the news in korea
they're korean newspapers or writing
about you uh you know
england
you're all over england you're on the
front page of the globe tabloids i'm
like
i had no idea the world worked this way
like the media
um like you know like i said in 1999 i
stopped watching the news
or television because of columbine but
then in 2009 now a decade later
i almost killed myself over that i mean
because it like it caused problems
within my family because i mean
everybody my dad was calling me up you
know you're on the radio getting
thrashed right now i mean
oh god that experience was just awful
and i was sincerely i mean i was trying
to make this film i thought it was
important and i just said you know hey i
got the idea from this story so i want
to make basically her story but i was
going to change all the names and all
this stuff and i just wanted to see what
the stockholm syndrome i was going to
explore the stockholm syndrome you know
and i thought that was really
interesting and that was always kind of
something
that i think i explored uh
subconsciously you know throughout you
know other you know some of my other
films
and um and then all of a sudden no
everyone in the world decided to hate me
and uh and uh
i i wasn't used to uh
being thrashed like you know i
interviewed me and that guy was a
nightmare just completely i had no idea
i didn't listen to this stuff and that
guy just um
i was like one of the worst experiences
of my life talking to that guy you know
i just like almost
like wanted to die after talking to him
you know and none of these people they
the whole thing none of these people
gave a you know and that's what
happened so i dropped the movie
um
it ruined my relationship i mean it
ruined so many things for me
and then
literally it was like that same time it
was like only a couple weeks before like
alyssa you know had been all over the
news so this was all happening at the
same time i was all over the news for
you know trying to make this human
trafficking thing and she was all over
the news and maybe that was it too maybe
i saw
all these accusations people don't want
to wait for anything like they hear oh
so and so uh just got you know raped by
uh or you know five girls just got raped
um they have a suspect his name is
so-and-so oh wait it's not him little
retraction and then that guy's life is
wrong i mean they don't give
one damn about running the media doesn't
care about ruining anybody's life you
know they ruin lives
in my opinion the media ruins lives left
and right they don't care they just want
headlines they just want a story and um
i think that
was one thing that made me want to jump
on it because i already felt like my
life was ruined i didn't i mean my life
literally felt ruined at that point and
i feel like i've been picking myself up
ever since now i feel finally back to
being me which is funny because now that
the movie's coming out i'm like oh
you know maybe now something else is
going to happen
but i think that that was a big
thing as i felt like i had nothing to
lose i felt like i had nothing to lose
at that point everything's screwed you
know right now for me um
why don't i just go tackle this subject
on this i can't make a story about a
victim why don't i make a story about a
murderer who i almost think might be a
victim because at least thinks he's a
victim of the media
so maybe that's it if that answers the
question because and then the thing with
making it then i started thinking she
actually didn't do it so that's a whole
other story and now i'm actually almost
convinced she didn't even do the murder
and that actually made me
think about my childhood which was
completely ruined by false accusations
and the court in the system and all this
stuff so
yeah maybe that answers the question i
felt i got nothing to lose i saw a lot
of myself i wanted to challenge the
media
um
it was it was the man with nothing to
lose i guess is maybe